hi I'm Susie Essman from Curb Your  Enthusiasm if you're like me there's  nothing better than kicking back and  relaxing after a long day but sometimes  it's hard to turn off the world and  de-stress without the right soundtrack  to get you there until now presenting  the sweet sounds of Susie there's no  music there's no tempo it's just me  Susie reciting my most soothing lines  from curb with absolutely no filler  featuring such classics as you sick  four-eyed [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of here  [ __ ] you you [ __ ] decapitated your sick  [ __ ] pervert the dog bit your penis what  are you [ __ ] kidding me  wait don't hurry dinner you're a fat  [ __ ] [ __ ] you heartless piece of  [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of my house and  more the collection has it all so why  wait listen to the sweet sounds of Susie  today and sleep like a baby tonight  you can thank me later listen to the  sweet sounds of susie presented by Curb  Your Enthusiasm available on Spotify  [Music]